one of the many things
that uh make you fascinating is that
you've played with diet as well and
you're
somewhat famous i would say for doing
low carb or playing with low carb or
meat based diets can you describe the
potential like what how you're thinking
about that has evolved and the potential
beneficial role of a carnivore diet or a
keto diet or a meat-based diet in
training as an ultra-marathon runner
yeah and i think like where a lot of
times things get confusing for people
here is the context of it too where it's
like they want an answer as to
what do i eat for endurance sport it's
like well endurance sport is quite wide
ranging as we've talked about many many
times here so there's going to be
differences i think in just like what
you want to maybe necessarily prioritize
uh
both for the event you're doing and the
intensity that's required for it the
training that's required for that event
and then also the individual component
too where i think this one often gets
overlooked where we tend to say like
well we've got all these olympic
medalists at the marathon and below
distance who are
you know eating a moderate to high
carbohydrate diet so everyone needs to
do that if they want to reach their
potential in you know say the 3k to the
marathon
and you know in a perfect world maybe
that would be true but there's a lot of
other variables that often get forgotten
then that could
positively or negatively impact that
decision choice so i think dr jeff volk
has done a great job of kind of
highlighting this in the sense that you
know when he works with people he works
with people in the health sphere as well
as the performance sphere
and you know he's one of the main guys
at virta health who's uh they've got
like a 60
success rate with working with folks
with type 2 diabetes to um reverse their
type 2 diabetes
uh and i mean that's an astounding when
you when you think of just any
nutritional protocol its success rate
they're all incredibly low they're very
very low and the big difference with his
is the coaching aspect of it like they
give support so these people like have
someone to turn to when they make a
mistake or if they're thinking about
doing something differently or they
don't know what to do rather than just
kind of throwing throwing it all up in
the air and quitting they they have a
resource there and that's probably a big
reason why that's the success rate that
they have with that is they put those
support mechanisms in place
that
picture needs to be carried into the
performance world or the running world
too where you know we may have just been
identifying
that
olympic distance athletes
that can tolerate a very large portion
of their diet coming from carbohydrate
is going to just it's going to filter
those ones towards the olympics filter
those towards interest
yeah and that doesn't mean that like
uh if we would have taken say the gold
medals in the 5k and put them on a low
carb diet they'd run faster they
probably wouldn't because we may have
already selected that that person's
thriving on carbohydrate
what i would be interested in is like
you have let's say we have someone with
equal talent
but got weeded out along the way
potentially because for whatever reason
they just weren't able to tolerate like
the both the training and the nutrition
requirements that they're being told to
do so the coaches kind of there's a
culture where the coaches would really
push a carb heavy diet and that that
would in itself would
do the filtering process of people that
are
not it would filter out the people that
are not able to tolerate carbs as part
of their training i mean i might be an
example of this actually where you know
you take someone where
uh they for whatever reason the carbs
aren't working for them like it's
unsustainable for them to continue that
path or if they do they might have a
shortened career so they might be able
to eke out a few really good years but
then you know they're not going to be
the person they're like wow that
person's 38 and they're still competing
at the olympics type of a person yeah uh
and you know you you put them on a low
carb diet uh
if you can control everything else like
their entire lifestyle is based around
training and racing
then uh you know they may
still have better potential by
introducing carbohydrates at a higher
level but if that's not going to if
that's not going to be sustainable for
them as a person
then you know what's the point kind of
at that unless they want to be like a
kind of a spark in the pan so to speak i
just feel good eating meat performance
wise well i think there's that group too
and they may just not be the olympians
yeah and so we're not talking
i guess this conversation has several
layers one is for the olympics and
one is for like
what is it
active
athletes they're like amateurs whatever
whatever category i put myself into like
people that exercise regularly
and then um
maybe people and then there's people who
like exercise rarely
so on all of those fronts i mean
do you think it's possible to live a
happy
active life eating meat only
or mostly meat
yeah what have you learned about this
yeah i think so for for some context
like i followed what i would call a low
carbohydrate diet for the last 10 years
and just like kind of the training i
periodize it to a degree where there are
parts of my training where i do bring
back a little more carbohydrate and
there's periods of my training
especially like the offseason where i'm
like very low and i might be like kind
of in that ballpark of uh like you know
ketogenic strict ketogenic or no
carbohydrates for for periods of time
and what kind of food are we talking
about what's what's a strict low-carb
diet i've ranged everywhere from like
mostly plant-based low-carb keto to like
mostly animal based i've very rarely
gone much more than like two weeks
strict where it's like i'm strict
carnivore or strict plant-based or
anything like that like we're talking
probably more like 95
at that at the peak um in terms of any
type of like like longer lasting
uh
from my personal experience of like
being like either in like the animal
food camp or like the plant-based camp
kind of of a process
um so i've tried all of them things that
stayed consistent over the 10 years as a
kind of the macronutrient profile that
i've done throughout the course so one
didn't win over the other in terms of
meat based versus plant-based oh for me
meat based definitely what was i mean i
was i was my highest meat consumption in
2019 and that was by far my best racing
season
yeah we keep coming back to that year
that was a good year for many reasons
philosophically and nutritionally yeah
only 2020 happened and now i haven't had
a really good chance to
improve
we'll see hopefully i've got some more
yeah some more in the tank that's
strange there's so most athletes that
compete at your level
have more carbs integrated into their
diets so what have you learned about
using meat in high performance
i think it's maybe less about the meat
and it's more about like what are you
what is it replacing
so
if we go if we step away from like me
specifically
and just like the people that because i
mean we're getting to the point i get
it's anecdotes but like like that's what
we have at the moment because there's i
mean there is actually a study being
done on like i think i guess they call
it hyper carnivore where they're like i
think above 80 percent of their intake
from meat
um and they're looking at a few
different things there but it's so weird
and i keep interrupting but it's so
weird that it sounds unhealthy
uh hyper carnivore yeah but it makes me
feel really good
so it's the individual thing right like
an individual thing
there's countless people now who
like and i'm not saying that they could
not have found another route myself
included like in 2011 when i switched
from moderate to high carbohydrate low
carbohydrate and saw some very
noticeable differences in the way i felt
the way i performed in all this stuff
that doesn't mean that there wasn't
another path i just did not find that
path and
the the
the fact that i found a path that was
producing the results i was looking for
is really all that matters in my mind
you know like
i don't really care if there was a
parallel path that works just as well or
you know something like that
because ultimately we only have one shot
at everything we're doing so like it'd
be great if i could go back and try four
or five different things well the
annoying thing is that the the body
adjusts to whatever the heck you're
doing so you can't it's hard to do good
science even on yourself yeah i've
referenced my 2019 racing season a few
times and it's like it'd be silly for me
to put all of the emphasis on my
nutrition plan for that because it also
comes with
two decades of endurance training so
it's possible and it's very likely that
a huge portion of that success was just
the culmination of a lot of work over
time from the training side of things
i just think like anytime you hyper
focus on one area or pick a couple
variables and just target those you find
yourself in a position where you are
you're putting other things in the most
uncharitable light possible
so
so then you have this situation where
like it's actually a combination of a
variety of different things so where are
the big movers and you know for me
nutritional shift was pretty clear that
that improved my sleep in my recovery
and i mean people can say
well there's the placebo effect which is
a very real concern but you know for me
personally a 10-year placebo effect
would be a quite lengthy placebo effect
and
i do think it's individual though i i
emphasize that a lot because i mean i've
worked with tons of people with this and
i do see a range from person to person
i've worked with people who come to me
and they're like strict keto and we
raise up their carbohydrates a bit and
they're like okay i feel way better
doing it this way and i've worked with
people who they come to me moderate
carbohydrate but they're interested
enough um
they want to try a lower carb so we you
know we titrate them down and i've had
clients where i'm like okay i'm gonna
give them this workout and they're gonna
wish they brought back a little bit of
carbohydrate and then they go and they
nail the workout and i'm just like
baffled that because they're different
from me and every time you know when you
have your own personal experience
the first kind of guttural response is
oh if i had done it would have gone this
way why did it go completely opposite
way for them and you kind of have to
just kind of step out of your own
perspective a bit and say like okay well
they're different you know for whatever
reason they're getting getting along
like this
i've had like
several moments in my life where you
kind of realized
the body is weird and it's weirder than
the average advice like one of them is
how well
i perform for my own standards when i
fast
uh first of all intellectually but
that's more known and and understandable
but like physically yeah the fact that i
could train like not eat 20 hours 24
hours
and then do a hard
like jiu jitsu session for like two
hours
like hard
it's incredible to me like this makes no
sense because i used to eat like many
times a day
of course you have to eat like you don't
want to eat too close to the training
session what's my thinking but you
definitely need to load up on carbs like
three hours before like in order to have
enough energy the fact that i could not
eat and have like incredible focus but
also athleticism like both
endurance and explosive i mean ggs is a
special thing it's like more like chess
yeah it's not like powerlifting no not
powerlifting olympic lifting or it's
like true explosiveness but that's
fascinating and it makes me wonder like
what other things are there to to um to
discover about yourself the the annoying
thing about food is it's delicious
and so it's hard to do good science on
yourself like to do
you know for two weeks or a month to do
like strict
no carbs and then maybe next month you
add 20 grams or 40 grams of carbs and
see how you actually feel right not like
in that moment but over a period of
several weeks and then doing everything
else like right with based on best
available science like with little
electrolytes and then vitamins but then
also like remove all the humans from
your life that affect you yep positively
or negatively because you might feel
amazing because you're hanging out with
cool people and then
uh you know like removing basically all
the variables
it's kind of fascinating and you kind of
all of us land in a place where we find
something that worked for us and then we
maybe use some of the placebo effect to
help us out to stick in that place and
then
uh i suppose that's the way to live life
like it's impossible to find the optimal
for any of us but carnivore is an
interesting
new kind of
caveat a new challenge to the
nutritional community because more and
more people seem to be doing well under
carnivore yeah well the nutrition
community is probably like we just got
done like dealing with the vegans and
now we got this opposite end of the
spectrum coming at us but i think well i
mean what this all tells
what this all tells me is like
there is uh for one like
in our food environment
like the failure rate of any one
approach at a population level is gonna
be incredibly high i mean it's why we
have you know what is it like 88 of the
population has some sort of like
metabolic syndrome
and it's it's like you know it's because
there's an endless quantity of
everything that you can get your hands
on for relatively cheap
um
and i think that's that that presents a
problem
if your mindset is going to be
we need this set of parameters for
nutrition and everyone needs to adhere
to that
or you're wrong
and it's like we'll tell that to the
person who like
went carnivore and cleared up some like
crazy skin ailment or something like
that that's a weird one yeah like where
the carnivore seems to treat
like
like depression uh-huh it's like like
mental stuff it's fascinating there's
all these stories again it's anecdotes
but it's like the mental one i think
may
i'm stepping out a bit on a limb here
but i want to say like some of the
research of dominic d'agostino and jeff
wallick was looking at
the ketogenic diet which
a carnivore diet is basically going to
be a part of a ketogenic i mean you
could always go like way too high on the
protein i guess but most people that i
see doing carnivore they're cognizant
enough
that at least if they're doing it for
therapeutic reasons they're not going
like you know 50 protein 50 they're more
like
70 30 80 20 something like that
and
and i think like
you you do see some some work with like
the brain and so the mental stuff i know
some of the i'm not sure if this was
part of the darpa funding that that
doctor
dominic de agustino had where they were
looking at things like mental stuff like
post-traumatic stress disorder and that
sort of stuff with with like a strict
ketogenic diet so i wonder if some of
that like the depression related stuff
has to do with that where now like their
body is just fueling their brain
differently than maybe they were in the
past but
that's just you know wild guesses on my
part
you